lo que tenemos aquí son 6 gráficas de
dispersión que muestran la relación
entre distintas variables por ejemplo en
esta gráfica tal vez en el eje de las x
tenemos la edad y en el eje de las yes
podríamos tener por ejemplo la
frecuencia de accidentes pero por
supuesto todo esto lo estoy inventando
en este momento podría ser cualquier
otro ejemplo pero podríamos decir que
estos son los datos de una encuesta
estadística y por ejemplo este valor
podría hacer cualquier valor pero
podríamos suponer que es la edad de 20
años y entonces lo que nos dice este
punto es que la frecuencia de accidentes
de personas de 20 años es esta de acá y
luego para las personas que tienen 21
años de edad tal vez esta es la
frecuencia de accidentes entonces las
personas que hacen estadística o
ciencias de datos recopilaron toda esta
información e hicieron esta gráfica de
dispersión que por cierto
se le llaman datos y variados lo cual
básicamente significa que tenemos datos
que consideran dos variables y que
estamos tratando de encontrar cuál es la
relación entre esas dos variables
estamos tratando de encontrar un patrón
en la forma en la que se relacionan y lo
que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
tratar de ajustar una línea a estos
datos pero también nos vamos a preguntar
si la relación entre estas dos variables
en estos dos ejes es no lineal nos vamos
a preguntar qué tan fuerte es esa
relación y si es positiva o negativa y
por supuesto también vamos a hablar
acerca de los valores atípicos entonces
empecemos pensando en si hay una
relación lineal o no lineal entre estas
dos variables dados estos datos
voy a sacar una herramienta que me
permite dibujar líneas rectas estos
datos si se ven como que puedo ajustar
una línea recta que refleje bastante
bien cómo se comportan una línea que
esté bastante
cerca de los datos definitivamente no
podemos poner una recta que pase por
todos los puntos pero si podemos poner
una que se acerque bastante a todos y
por supuesto estoy haciendo esto
simplemente con mi intuición hay métodos
numéricos que hacen las cosas de una
forma muy precisa pero por el momento la
estamos calculando a simple vista
podemos graficar una línea que se acerca
bastante y se ve más o menos así así es
que estos datos son bastante lineales
por lo que podemos decir que la relación
entre estas dos variables es lineal y
ahora podemos observar que conforme
aumenta una de las variables la otra
variable disminuye aunque ya está en
línea recta tiene una pendiente negativa
por lo que esta es una relación lineal
negativa
negativa pero además es una relación
bastante fuerte porque aunque si tenemos
algunos valores atípicos en realidad no
se encuentran tan distantes de la línea
están bastante cerca no están por acá
así es que hay una relación fuerte
lineal y negativa entre estas dos
variables bueno ahora vamos con el
siguiente ejemplo con la siguiente
gráfica de dispersión ponle una pausa
del vídeo y piensa acerca de la relación
entre estas dos variables bueno pues
parece que si podemos poner una línea
recta que represente la relación entre
estas variables podemos ajustar una
línea recta por aquí y parece en
términos generales que conforme una
variable aumenta la otra también aumenta
así es que esta es una relación positiva
pero también podemos ver que es una
relación débil un muy buen porcentaje de
los datos no se encuentran muy cerca de
la línea entonces es una relación débil
lo que estos datos nos están diciendo es
que conforme aumenta una de las
variables la otra variable también
aumenta más o menos con la misma
magnitud pero no necesariamente porque
aquí todos estos datos están bastante
dispersos aunque de todas formas yo
seguiría llamándole lineal ahora también
tenemos que hablar acerca de esta noción
de que hay valores atípicos si decimos
que esta línea está tratando de
describir a estos datos bueno pues aquí
tenemos algunos datos que se alejan
bastante de la línea entonces aunque
estemos diciendo que es una relación
lineal débil positiva este dato que
tenemos por acá tiene un valor
relativamente alto en el eje vertical
pero tiene un valor relativamente
pequeño en el eje horizontal y eso lo
vuelve un valor atípico porque está
bastante lejos de la línea que está
aproximando a todos estos datos también
podríamos considerar que este es un dato
con valores atípicos aunque al final de
cuentas cuáles
datos tienen valores atípicos puede
resultar un poco subjetivo los datos
atípicos son básicamente los que se
alejan del resto de los datos por
ejemplo este también podría ser un dato
atípico vamos a escribirlo por aquí
atípico bueno y ahora pasemos a la
siguiente gráfica de dispersión ponle
pausa al vídeo y piensa si la relación
entre estas dos variables es lineal o no
lineal si es débil o fuerte y si es
positiva o negativa mientras tanto voy a
poner por aquí la herramienta para
dibujar rectas y vamos a empezar a
ajustar este modelo parece como que es
bastante sencillo ajustar una línea
recta a estos datos parece ser una
relación positiva conforme aumenta una
de las variables la otra también aumenta
así es que esta es una relación positiva
y además es fuerte porque todos los
datos se acercan muchísimo a la recta
que así no tenemos valores atípicos de
hecho hasta parece como si fuera un
recta gorda de datos y definitivamente
es una relación lineal entonces esta es
una relación lineal fuerte positiva y
además casi no tenemos datos atípicos
este es el dato que más se aleja de la
línea pero en realidad no se aleja tanto
así es que estos datos describen muy
bien esta tendencia pero bueno ahora
vamos con la siguiente gráfica de
dispersión podemos ajustar este modelo
con una línea recta y se vería más o
menos así otra vez lo estoy haciendo a
simple vista no estoy haciendo cálculos
que sí se pueden hacer con estos datos
se pueden utilizar métodos
computacionales para encontrar de una
forma muy precisa una línea que minimice
la suma de las distancias de todos estos
puntos a dicha línea pero bueno parece
como que esta es una relación positiva
es una relación débil porque los datos
no se encuentran tan cerca de la línea
de hecho hay algunos que se alejan
bastante y bueno si es un
relación lineal entonces esta es una
relación lineal débil positiva y bueno
por supuesto hay valores atípicos por
ejemplo este está bastante lejos del
resto de los datos pero bueno vamos con
el siguiente la relación entre estas
variables es positiva o negativa y es
fuerte o débil y también es lineal o no
lineal bueno pues yo creo que aquí lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es
preguntarnos si es una relación lineal o
una no lineal vamos a sacar nuestra
regla y podemos tratar de colocar una
recta que aproxime a todos estos datos
pero si colocamos una recta por acá
podemos observar como estos valores
pareciera como que se están doblando a
partir de esta línea también parece en
general que conforme una variable crece
la otra decrece pero no están
decreciendo de una forma lineal parece
como que una línea curva describiría
mejorar estos datos
entonces vamos a borrar la línea recta
podemos dibujar una curva más o menos
así y parece como que esta curva
describe mucho mejor estos datos por lo
que podemos decir que esta es una
relación no lineal y los datos están
suficientemente cerca de la línea por lo
que yo diría que es una relación fuerte
así es que es una relación no lineal
fuerte y negativa porque conforme
aumenta una de las variables la otra
disminuye relación no lineal fuerte y
negativa así es que esta es una relación
no lineal relativamente fuerte y
negativa y si nos ponemos a pensar en
cuál podría ser un dato atípico bueno
pues este podría ser un dato atípico
pero repito estamos haciendo esto a
simple vista hay métodos muy precisos
para calcular todo este tipo de cosas
pero bueno vamos con la última gráfica
de dispersión sacamos la regla
vamos a colocarla acá a mí me parece que
esta es una relación negativa es lineal
y es bastante fuerte aunque por supuesto
tiene ahí varios datos atípicos y parece
que se aproxima bastante bien a los
datos ok
esta es una relación lineal
razonablemente fuerte y negativa pero
aquí claramente tenemos datos atípicos
porque se encuentran bastante alejados
del resto de los datos pero bueno espero
que este vídeo ayude a que te sientas
más familiarizado con este tipo de
terminología pero también es muy
importante mantener siempre presente que
algunas de estas cosas son muy
subjetivas hay casos que son más obvios
que otros y muchas veces queremos hacer
comparaciones por ejemplo aquí esta es
una relación mucho más fuerte que la
relación que tenemos por acá porque los
datos se encuentran mucho más cerca
a la línea y esta relación por acá
definitivamente es una relación no
lineal pero también puede depender de
cómo quieres escribir tus datos
algunas veces hacemos algunas
comparaciones o incluso algunas veces
describimos los datos de una forma un
poco más subjetiva